bill I mean that is your background here
is absolutely your background but I
think it's probably when you were
talking about how many lines you have to
learn for bodyguard and then they're
gone and you're just getting another
script and I'm doing a television series
now and you've done so many and I you
know it's just great to be able to take
a play and then repeat it you know
actually that's the gift is to say well
that's when you have some fun yeah
because you can try different things and
you can sort of edit yourself as you go
along but then early on in theater and
this would have been enough to put me
off I think bill didn't I mean I'm
smiling I did awhile you had properly
serious accident yes I did I was in
college in the time period where
everybody was doing a lot of physical
theater and we were creating an ice
church for epson's brand one of the
seldom done poetic dramas of the
Norwegian master and but and I was brand
and climbing the top of the ice tree
Church created by people's bodies
somebody slipped and moved or something
and I fell 15 feet and I hit my head I
was in a coma for two and a half days
and and I'm still doing theatres in dead
people who came along to see when this
is a great fella it was like II really
yeah but you're still you still carry
the scars yes I lost my sense of smell
from that yeah forever
that cop tried to get it back actually
I'm there's some interesting holistic
treatments and London's got a kind of a
cutting edge leader of the world I think
in a lot of different policy and I'm
trying it on to get you to get my smart
back yeah do you want it back at this
point Oh Graham yeah are you sure
is it Pleasant now
that's a weird sense so you can't smell
something and have some idea of how it
will taste
you have to taste it hold up a t-shirt
you go it looks clean presumably you put
it on but I'm very useful for certain
things you know yeah yeah you can send
me into cleaning you in yeah in there
right away have you don't state all
completely yeah I you know I had to do a
movie about wine and yeah faking it
terribly but maybe I'll get that this
back thing in London I don't want you to
the back I think I think it'll freak you
out if you get it back it's gonna stink
yeah
don't go on the tube
[Laughter]
[Music]
you